you should always say what you're
thankful every day but this is a
thankful opportunity you have your
family and friends around and obviously
you have the most delicious meal of the
people what you're thankful for and you
break bread if I had to get my top five
favorite sides right my top five
favorite sides and I'm all about the
combination the combination like I know
some people don't like their food
touching right I love my food touch so
like all my foods have to be colled
together type so I'mma put it like this
right so five will probably be my
stuffing and it has to have the gravy on
right the stuffing gravy has to be Mando
Mando um stuffing and you got to put
stuffing SLG gravy it's combination
combination combination everything's
about the combination right um yes there
we go right number four we have to go uh
people I'm glad someone said fried
turkey people do not know about fried
turkey you got have turkey with a little
bit of gravy but honestly you could do
turkey with a little bit of gravy but
I'm the type of guy I like turkey with
uh the yam sauce the yam juice you take
the turkey with the yam juice right um
your sweet potato juice so say turkey
sweet potato juice turkey with the sweet
potato juice food always got a touch
right um so so that that'll be number
four right um number three for me would
definitely be about uh uh oh I would say
the cream corn the cream corn uh yam
juice with the turkey yam juice turkey
the cream corn when you have a delicious
cream corn oh man oh man oh cream corn
all right um number two um collard
greens and hot sauce if you don't got
collard greens in your plate like true
ghetto out the South Uptown Vibe collard
greens with red hot oh I I can't even
come to your Thanksgiving I can't come I
can't come you're not like like come on
you got to have the coll greens with the
red hot collard greens with the red hot
right um and then uh and then number one
when I tell you this is this is what
gets the H you feel me um you got to get
the mac and cheese with the Gams and you
got to put it together for the
combination the combination the mac and
cheese and yams go together if your Mac
and yams AR together I question you if
you don't got yams and Mac together
you're just not normal um you're just
not normal you can't be at my
Thanksgiving I'm not coming to your
Thanksgiving um but this is this is what
a real plate looks like this is a real
plate my plate be about I'm gonna be two
gonna be like 260 next week after this
game I'm glad we we we get a week off
because this is about to be crazy right
um that is the top five for me without a
doubt without a doubt that is is my top
five argue with your mama that's the top
five period mac and cheese and yams
together period they got a touch they
got to touch they just go well um too
well together
um I would say you know my favorite
thing about Thanksgiving truly is when
all my family comes in it's really the
game nights like the games that me and
my family play it honestly if your
Thanksgiving don't got Tonk um
Spades uh you know maybe sh
raids uh some scatories something like
that and it your your Thanksgiving
really Ain hit y'all really ain't that
close my my Thanksgiving got all of that
and it's just all family laughing joking
uh and things like that that's the best
part of Thanksgiving uh catching up with
your family and obviously the throwback
Stories the throwback stories of your
uncles your moms and them is too great
um it's something that I can't I can't
it's something that's just it's it's
Untouchable to me um
and and a typical uh Thanksgiving my mom
actually works up at 5:30 a.m. on
Thanksgiving to start cooking um she she
does everything she prepares everything
the night before the day of Thanksgiving
goes to the game leaves early to make
sure I got a nice fresh plate for us to
eat after the game when everyone leaves
the game I got like 20 people in town
this week for Thanksgiving can't wait to
be with all of them um because they're
also special to me and you know I can't
wait it's going to be a fun weekend it's
GNA be a fun game you know when I got
certain people in town my son will be in
town so that might give you a clue how
well this game might go you know the
little lions back in town